[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24
este es un magazine informativo 100
dedicado al continente africano mi
nombre liliana valencia aquí damos una
mirada en profundidad a los hechos de
actualidad de la semana en la cuna de la
humanidad
se cumplieron seis meses desde que la
organización mundial de la salud declaró
la pandemia de kobe 19 y áfrica ya
supera los 1.3 millones de contagios
marruecos el país más turístico del
continente sufre las consecuencias de
una estricta cuarentena
en mali la junta militar y varios
partidos políticos acordaron un lapso de
18 meses para la transición de gobierno
después del golpe de estado del pasado
18 de agosto sin embargo la oposición
rechazó dicha propuesta
y esta semana tiene lugar el quinto
áfrica fill festival un encuentro
cinematográfico donde participan films
de más de 26 países debido a la pandemia
el evento será virtual y las películas
se podrán ver de manera gratuita
iniciamos entonces con la información en
áfrica siete días el continente africano
superó los 1.3 millones de contagios de
kobe 19 cuando se cumplen seis meses de
la declaratoria la pandemia por parte de
la omct organización había pronosticado
que el continente debía prepararse para
lo peor pero sostuvo que el índice de
mortalidad en el continente está por
debajo de la media mundial en otras
causas debido a la juventud de la
población pero veremos un repaso por las
cifras de los cinco países más afectados
de la región
todavía continúa siendo el epicentro de
la enfermedad con más de 649 mil 793
positivos y 15 mil 447 decesos en
segundo lugar esta egipto que rodea los
101.000 9 contagios y suma más de 5.600
muertos también le sigue en marruecos
que rebasa los 86 mil 600 casos
positivos pero cuya tasa de sesos es
inferior a la de nigeria que cuenta con
mil 82 muertos y más de 56 mil 200 o
contagios en quinto lugar se encuentra
gana con casi 45 mil 400 contagios y
unos 286 fallecidos como veíamos
sudáfrica sigue siendo el país más
afectado por la pandemia del continente
sin embargo ya superó el pico de los
contagios y siguen a la baja desde
ciudad del cabo nuestro corresponsal
salem fayad nos entregó detalles de esta
información
el pico de la pandemia parece ya haber
pasado en el sur de áfrica o al menos el
primer pico en sudáfrica se han
promediado más o menos 1000 casos
diarios en los últimos días lo cual es
sin duda una noticia de alivio aunque
las autoridades han llamado a no bajar
la guardia de hecho no se presentaron
altos repuntes en el número de casos
después de que se relajara el
confinamiento y tampoco he tenido que
usar si algunos de los hospitales de
campaña que se implementaron de manera
preventiva cuando estábamos en pleno
pico de la pandemia otros países de la
región como en la media por ejemplo no
se han visto tan afectados namibia ya
abrió sus fronteras aunque las
sudafricanas se mantienen cerradas y en
general la región del áfrica subshariana
se esperaba que fuera una de las más
afectadas por la pandemia a nivel global
este no ha sido el caso y tanto los
expertos locales como internacionales
han admitido que encuentran inexplicable
este fenómeno el impacto económico sin
embargo en sudáfrica ya se ha
pronosticado a que iba a ser muy fuerte
pero esta semana obtuvimos por fin en
cifras oficiales y se ha dicho que la
economía del país se ha encogido en un
51 por ciento lo cual es mucho más de lo
y en parte las suspensiones en las
actividades de minería y de la
construcción que explican esta crisis
económica finalmente a sudáfrica también
ha suspendido las pruebas clínicas con
la vacuna de la universidad de oxford
después de que se reportaran algunas
posibles complicaciones con este
tratamiento
otro de los países con más contagios en
el continente africano es marruecos
aunque el índice de mortalidad está
también por debajo de la media mundial y
también de la medida del continente
desde marraquech nos informa nuestra
corresponsal sofía català en la región
del magreb en el norte de áfrica ha
habido un fuerte incremento de casos de
kobe 19 especialmente en marruecos que
ya es el tercer país más afectado del
continente habiendo superado los 75 mil
casos positivos en este país se están
registrando alrededor de 2000 casos
diarios cifras que no se habían
alcanzado todavía desde el inicio de la
pandemia a los hospitales de las
regiones más afectadas se encuentran a
saturados y se ha vuelto a prolongar el
estado de emergencia sanitaria también
mucha preocupación en libia un país
dividido y devastado por una guerra
multinacional desde hace casi una década
y cuyo sistema de salud se encuentra
hecho pedazos según datos que maneja el
gobierno de acuerdo nacional respaldado
por la onu se estarían registrando
alrededor de 1000 casos diarios pero
podrían ser muchos más porque no hay
datos de las zonas que no controla este
gobierno que son en gran parte del
territorio
en el caso de túnez el país menos
afectado de la región se están volviendo
a registrar centenares de casos cada día
y argelia es la excepción es el país de
la región donde disminuyen los contagios
diarios pero siguen preocupando las
muertes se han registrado más de 1500
desde el inicio de la pandemia y aun con
menos contagios que marruecos argelia es
el país de la región más afectado por la
tasa de mortalidad y es que marruecos es
el país más visitado de áfrica el
turismo representa el 7 por ciento del
producto interno bruto y genera más de 4
millones de empleos
marrakech es su capital turística pues
acumula más del 30 por ciento del total
de estancias en el país y también en la
ciudad más afectada por la crisis del
coi 19 desde marzo la concurrida medida
de la ciudad roja se encuentra vacía y
los trabajadores resisten en medio de la
incertidumbre
la famosa plaza se maligna de marrakech
una de las ciudades más turísticas de
áfrica desde hace siglos un escenario al
aire libre que reúne a artistas
comerciantes locales y visitantes de
todas partes del mundo
adil es uno de los pocos comerciantes
que mantiene abierto su puesto familiar
a pesar de la pandemia apenas tiene
clientes pero aún así prefiere abrir y
darle vida a la plaza vengo aquí de vez
en cuando para trabajar y para sentirme
a gusto con el lugar
el turismo representa el 7 por ciento
del pib de marruecos y marrakech
concentra gran parte de la actividad
turística con más de un tercio de las
estancias
nadie es empleada de este riad un
inmueble tradicional convertido en casa
de huéspedes bienvenida desde marzo está
cerrado y sin perspectivas de futuro
asume que la dependencia del turismo les
ha abocado a una gran crisis el motivo
son los ciudadanos humildes viviremos de
hecho ya estamos viviendo una gran
crisis económica porque la mayoría de
marroquíes trabajamos en el turismo
entre los trabajadores más afectados
están los conductores de transportes
turísticos los parados reciben 200
dólares al mes de la seguridad social
pero tal y como explica el presidente de
la federación hay muchos no declarados
los trabajadores que viven el día a día
hoy se han quedado sin subsidio hoy se
enfrentan a la incerteza
en medio de la incertidumbre sobre la
reapertura en marruecos siguen
aumentando los casos de kobe 19 y la
capital del turismo
marrakech resiste sumida en la
precariedad y la dependencia a este
sector
cambiamos de información y vamos ahora a
mari donde la oposición rechazó el plan
para la transición de gobierno
presentado por la junta militar y varios
grupos políticos hacia el golpe de
estado que llevó a la renuncia del ex
presidente ibrahim abu bakr kate al
pasado 18 de agosto los líderes
opositores argumentan que dicho plan
deja la puerta abierta para que los
militares sigan gobernando el país y
añaden que no cumple con la exigencia
mayoritaria de que el presidente y el
primer ministro interinos sean
personalidades de la vida sin ser
visible para es difícil estar satisfecho
porque el trabajo que se requiere es
enorme para vice
es enorme
[Música]
aceptar esta propuesta y hacerse cargo
del país y creo que deberíamos dejarlo
en manos de los militares
creo que los civiles deben ceder el paso
al ejército por el bien de todos que se
vayan los demás y se preparen para las
elecciones eso es lo mejor que podemos
hacer una tragedia minera enluta la
república democrática del congo donde se
calcula que al menos 50 personas
murieron tras el colapso de una mina de
oro el derrumbe ocurrió luego de fuertes
lluvias y las autoridades locales
estiman que alrededor de 50 mineros
quedaron atrapados en el pozo de la mina
aunque admiten que resulta difícil
calcular con precisión cuántas personas
se encontraban en el interior debido a
que la mayoría de estos mineros trabajan
de manera informal y en condiciones
precarias además de a menudo
clandestinas
vamos con información cultural porque a
partir de este 15 de septiembre los
amantes del cine africano podrán
disfrutar de los mejores filmes que
participan en el festival de cine
africano de quibdó un evento que se iba
a realizar desde el departamento de
chocó en la costa pacífico colombiana
pero debido a la pandemia se desarrolla
ahora de manera virtual
el objetivo del kit de áfrica feel
festival es generar nuevos lazos entre
áfrica y sus diásporas con uno de los
territorios de mayoría poblacional afro
más representativos de colombia en
france 24 hablamos con el productor
realizador y cineasta wilfried más samba
que nos contó los detalles del concurso
y de la muestra cinematográfica desde el
próximo 15 y hasta el 19 de septiembre
la plataforma de streaming burnett
puntocom permitirá el acceso gratuito a
las películas de la selección oficial
del kit de áfrica fin festival 2020 las
diez categorías cuentan con una
curaduría incluyente que refleja la
diversidad del pueblo afro y sus
visiones del mundo
con miradas críticas y más justas sobre
el mundo en que habitamos entre ellas
tendríamos las mujeres directoras jazz
por dos bellas jazz por americana áfrica
contemporánea y urbana afro futurismo
resistencia ancestral y memoria magreb
cine afro colombiana y el país habitado
que es la república democrática del
congo para este año 2020 el evento de
inauguración será desde casa y por eso
estaremos apoyando por la alcaldía de
quibdó y la secretaria de la cultura del
choco a través de la plataforma de
streaming un net puntocom y las redes
sociales del festival estaremos
transmitiendo y también finalizamos con
música desde colombia donde un grupo de
artistas afro colombianos lanzaron una
nueva canción titulada quien los mató se
trata de un grito de dolor ante las
recientes masacres que han tenido lugar
en el país recientemente
[Música]
ellos son hendrix ni a góngora alexis
play y junior jein quienes se unieron
con el reconocido director de cine 84
jon y hendrix para producir esta canción
y sus videoclips inspirados en el dolor
de las madres de los cinco jóvenes afro
colombianos que fueron asesinados
recientemente en el barrio llano verde
de la ciudad de cali en el pacífico
colombiano pues es sencillo piden
respeto por la vida a los jóvenes y
justicia para las familias de las
biblias en archivo y otra historia la
costa del país con la clase obrera que
se muere impulsada
[Música]
hay sangre
no sé
con estas imágenes finalizamos este
capítulo de áfrica siete días pero los
invitamos a continuar con nosotros en
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
para ampliar la información de américa
latina y el mundo y por supuesto aquí
con nosotros quédense éstos france24
[Música]
realizarse con
de ruby cortes en los penales y sigo la
justicia que este caso sea claro y que
no quede impune como casi siempre hace
nada la vida
lo primero que dice elevan
somos amor eterno y fernando somos
víctimas del sistema
pero el cuerpo no se rinde
no no no
tiene dueño
y enumera
[Música]